so I'm particularly happy to be here
today talking about teen health because
during the last couple of weeks we've
seen many teens who really emerged as
heroic leaders inspiring the public and
spurring action on gun control in the US
and in doing so they've shown remarkable
acts of bravery and strength today I
want to talk about a type of hero
that's similarly brave strong and
inspiring though they might not be as
visible and these are teens with chronic
conditions chronic health conditions so
first I'm going to set the stage a
little bit I'll be talking about
adolescents in the u.s. today most of my
talk will focus on the US but I'm happy
to discuss global trends and speak with
people who are looking at what
healthcare looks like we're globally
after the talk the good news is that
most adolescents in the US are
considered healthy when we look at
traditional medical measures like
mortality rates use of health services
at incidents of disease and there's even
more good news teens are smoking
cigarettes less they're drinking less
than previous generations drunk driving
has gone down teen pregnancy is at an
all-time low but the incidence and
prevalence of chronic conditions is
rising and this is true in most
developed and developing countries the
World Health Organization predicts that
chronic health conditions will
constitute the main cause of death in
adolescents by 2020 surpassing accidents
and homicide so we can see here kind of
a staggering increase over an 18-year
period starting with 1994
I just put data from two studies up here
and and these are results that might
seem outdated but the office of
Adolescent Health gives 31% as its
current estimate for the number of
adolescents who have at least one
chronic condition so I chose these two
because they're reliably comparable
studies show generally the increase it's
also estimated that 13% of adolescents
have two or more conditions so thinking
about what it means to be an adolescent
today
might be different from what it used to
mean much of the increase in chronic
health conditions is from some common
chronic problems so these relate to
mental health and learning particularly
ATD and ADHD but depression and anxiety
are on the rise so for example these
charts show the prevalence of major
depressive episodes in 2014 for
adolescents on the top and young adults
on the bottom so I mean y-axis we have
percentage and it's truncated at 12 so
this looks much more learning than it
actually is on first glance but I
include these to sort of show that the
trend is going up so episodes rose in
2014 from under 9 percent in 2005 to 11
percent in 2014 and adolescents with a
with a modest increase in young adults
as well from 2005 to 2014 so while this
is only one measure of mental health
it's an important signal that indicates
a trend asthma is another driver of
chronic illnesses in adolescents between
1976 so going a little bit further back
now to 2016 and we can see it going from
under 4% in the 96 some excuse me 76 to
80 period to 1 in 10 in 2016 the final
large driver is obesity or being
overweight so obesity rates have more
than tripled from under 6% in 1980 to
roughly 21 percent in 2015 to 16 so
fortunately not all chronic illnesses
cause severe disruption to daily life or
limited activity but when we look across
different conditions that do limit
activity in teens we can see that
overall these are also increasing so
going back a little further now to 1960
we see that adolescents with special
healthcare needs were under about 2% of
the population this is increasing - in
2010 reached over 15% so I showed these
as background slides to show that teens
will be engaging in health care
differently in the past
supporting teen health meant teaching
teens to avoid things like smoking
drinking risky sexual behavior and
cultivating self-care skills but teens
are having more difficulties now with
chronic illnesses and basic self-care so
we need to think about management as a
strategy and how computing can support
that rather than just prevention so
let's put kind of a face on this and
introduce you to a persona who
represents a type of team that I work
with a lot I'd like to introduce you to
Bren
so Bren is 15 she's just been diagnosed
with osteosarcoma so this is a type of
cancer that occurs in the long bones
like our arms and our legs and so she's
considered to have a complex chronic
condition Sheila wrestle with it for at
least 12 months she'll require specialty
pediatric care and some period of
hospitalization
so Brenda lies on her family um and they
are really the ones who end up
coordinating her care taking her to
visits calling in to the clinic when
they're concerned and Brenda's also
experiencing kind of normal social
developmental stuff so she's finding
friends with interests are similar to
hers she's cultivating her identity
getting involved in projects that are
interesting to her and most of the time
she just wants to be treated like a
normal fifteen-year-old since her
diagnosis her life her parents lives
have completely changed she has to miss
school her mom or dad might leave work
early for routine hospital visits and
doctor appointments and she's sort of
navigating now these two worlds
communication and coordination can be
extremely complex so I kind of put a
stand in here for an oncologist but this
actually represents an entire network of
caregivers nurses radiologists Child
Life specialists so Bren had a clean
bill of health before her diagnosis so
she's likely to have a good outcome with
treatment but she'll need to engage in
follow-up activities over a period of
many years
she might encounter some survivorship
effects these have long-term impacts on
digestive health reproductive health and
she'll be dealing with these potentially
throughout her life
so we have a challenge right Brad is
developing into an adult she's dependent
on her parents but she's ramping up her
autonomy teens in this case are often
treated as either young children or
adults their perspectives on the illness
are really essential to capture right
and directly Drive treatment decisions
they need to be involved about decisions
like should I get surgery do I need to
get something amputated while we don't
think about navigating the healthcare
system as a skill that teens need to
learn in fact we're seeing that with the
higher prevalence and chronic illness
one in three will start to need to learn
this right during their teenagers so how
can HCI help Bren and teens like her
well we conducted a field study at
Children's Healthcare of Atlanta where
we conducted 38 interviews observations
of consultations we interviewed parents
and teens separately that was really
important for us methodologically
and we found some clear directions for
design so a highlight some that
pertained to the rest of the talk many
more in the paper that i'm citing and
happy to share that if you're interested
but first teens in our study needed to
take gradual ownership of health care
needs and they weren't necessarily
seeing a lot of opportunity to do that
there's a lot of things that this
comprises but one of the things I'll
point to you today is recognizing and
communicating their experiences this
tended to be extremely difficult for
them so we saw that both teens and
parents needed private communication
channels with clinicians and they often
tried to kind of protect one another
from the emotional distress that came
with talking about difficult illness
experiences so teens shielding of
information typically manifested as
hiding symptoms from parents and not
wanting to surprise or worry them and
not wanting to delay them because they
knew how busy they were and how how many
things they would have to do and balance
as well as sort of take them into a
clinic and receive care
the other important finding here is that
teens
struggle to make sense of their
diagnosis their health status and their
progress and one of the key things that
we saw here is that they used diagnostic
data whenever they could and compared
diagnostic data over time to help them
understand status in progress so we see
a couple selected quotes there are many
that came up in our study but they said
things like I want to see how my
platelets have gotten better over time
how my MRIs have changed over time or in
T tens case these scans make me feel a
little bit like I'm in there I can see
the tumor they point out so I can see
what's wrong with me they don't have to
tell me in some weird way another big
takeaway from the study was that
caregivers both clinical and family
family members had difficulty
understanding the patient experience and
the teens that we studied really tired
of being probed with questions so we
heard things like a lot of times I
really don't want to talk to them about
how I'm doing the biggest question I
hated being asked is are you okay how
are you feeling I'm fine until you come
in here asking me all these questions so
talking about experiences was the most
challenging part of communication with
physicians for the parents that we spoke
with and teens found it really difficult
to so with these in mind let's look at
sort of two major directions for HCI
research that can start to address how
computing can make things a little bit
easier for bread and her family so I see
these relating to associate technical
systems and personal systems when I talk
about socio technical systems I'll talk
about systems that that manage data and
in some of the complications inherent in
creating and maintaining those systems
so first we need to understand the socio
technical context that creates
constraints around coordination and
communication and ultimately bren's
participation her ability to own these
data a lot of health data will be
generated during Brent's care and her
everyday life so how can we use this
data to promote family coordination
engagement and knowledge
this is harder than it sounds because
there's a lot of assumptions about these
data that we can't necessarily make and
I'll go into to what these are in a
little bit so the other kind of major
direction I see is relating to is
basically related to personal systems so
how do we design personal systems to
tackle some of the problems that we
talked about when we do design we have
to think about things like participatory
approaches differently for example we
have to consider the needs of the family
we have to treat the family as a unit
and the design process and we have to
understand what kinds of design insights
can we really get from a family who was
going through this so first kind of
looking at socio technical systems
brenn will have an electronic health
record she might have several and what
twenty years of medical informatics and
HCI research has taught us is that we
can engage patients better by providing
them information about their own health
in a way that they can easily understand
many people have direct access to health
data now through personal health records
or online patient portals so working
with Children's Healthcare of Atlanta
we did a mixed-methods study so we
investigated experiences accessing an
online health record portal that
contained Tian's health records portal
here means that included also some other
features like not only diagnostic test
results and notes but things like
electronic messaging appointment
scheduling visit visit reviews and
medication prescription refills so both
patients and parents could access it if
they both gave permission and we wanted
to know if after logging in and using it
for a while would parents and teens have
different experiences using it so we
audited 19 months of usage and we
followed up with surveys and interviews
and I have three selected survey
questions here
we found that teens agreed slightly more
than their parents that using the system
would lead them to ask questions or had
led them to ask questions that they
wouldn't have known to ask before
that they knew more about their health
and they found it less difficult to keep
track of information in the system and
this was interesting for us because most
of the work that has looked at online
engagement with health record portals
and health records in general has
focused on older audiences so we're
seeing that that the younger audience
was more receptive to use of these
health record systems in general but
when we presented this work at a medical
informatics conference we learned that
access to this kind of data and the
access that our study participants had
isn't necessarily the norm some of this
has to do with laws governing
confidentiality but not all so federal
laws mandate confidential health
services for federally funded dependents
so no electronic trail can betray that
confidentiality but privacy law is very
at the state level and there's sometimes
ambiguous about whether adolescents can
actually control personal information
even about whether they consent they can
consent excuse me to receiving
particular treatments so to sum up it's
an ambiguous age but systems have to
embody unambiguous rules about access to
electronic health records and an online
portal features so several professional
organizations have called for
improvements to the design of health IT
to address privacy challenges the
American Academy of Pediatrics said
health and from information systems
currently lack the capability to allow
for protection of the privacy and
security of health information for
minors and this has been echoed by other
professional societies so we teamed up
with researchers at Cornell jessica
anchor and marianne Charcot to
characterize the diversity and
adolescent portal policies across a
range of institutions and determine the
factors that kind of influence
decision-making about how to actually
implement and customize health record
systems at an institutional level
so we conducted semi-structured
interviews with chief medical
information officers and other health IT
administration and executives we
complemented our interview data with
survey data from CM iOS across the
country at centers that both serve
pediatric populations and have EHRs
deployed to manage patient data so our
goal is to kind of maximize the
diversity of the geography and the type
of medical organization so we use census
regions for stratification looking you
know so these are sort of how they
cluster according to census regions when
we look at them by zip code we see it
the actual distribution across the US
and so we do see some skew for example
California is over-represented we asked
questions about what EHR privacy
features were implemented their
decision-making process whether they
needed guidance and their general
experience the big takeaway here is that
policies established very different
degrees of adolescent access from none
too partial to complete access ages from
10 to 18 years degrees of parental
access and types of information
considered sensitive so our first
takeaway is that there's a lot of
variability we found that it wasn't
necessarily variability that made sense
so for hospitals that saw a lot of
chronic conditions with where family
code management is really important
sometimes you'd see policies like no
access when they turn 13 we we just
locked them out there's there's no
online record available so this chart
combines results from both studies and
we've clustered it by all possible ages
at which an institution could give
access so if you look across medical
centers in our studies and ask what age
are adolescents granted full access or
orful access with parental permission it
looks something like this each possible
age 10 to 18 is listed on the left there
the colors red if the medical
organization does not grant access green
if they do in purple if they allow
access but only with permission so if
it's half green and half red it means
that half of the medical centers in our
study would allow someone who say 13 to
their online health record and half
would not I like this because it kind of
shows where adolescents get pulled right
so depending on where you would go to
seek care you might be pulled in a very
different direction right to either
receive or not receive access to your
online record and it becomes really
clear where the muddy area is so we kind
of can see the end beauty really easily
here yeah intent here is this
they just didn't it's like why not give
them access so we didn't have we didn't
find a theoretical grounding for this we
did find that that state law wait so we
figured that state law would really
dictate policy it was not the primary
contributor to to policies but address
its but the inconsistency is problematic
right so we want to prevent inadvertent
breaches of privacy
we need adolescent and parental trust in
the medical system so you can imagine
that people are going to feel really
frustrated right if at one point they
have the record and then something that
was transparent and available all of a
sudden is is unavailable but when we
look at rationale for why we found that
concerns about confidentiality and
discussion of sensitive health topics
were the key things that led that that
led medical centers to sort of lock down
records so one organization cited the
pressure of parents demanding access to
change passwords as the reason for not
having any portal access during
adolescence so in interview 2 we learned
you know allowing access could set up a
vertical hierarchy in terms of the
pressures coming from the parents that
adolescents give them their passwords so
ultimately we put it to bed and said
there just isn't any access but for
those who locked both parties out
lack of controls of the system that was
problematic so they don't have the fine
grain access controls that they need to
mark certain things private without them
automatically populating the portal so
in some in some sense you know not
populating it because you can't be sure
that it'll be populated with
compromising information or that it
would betray privacy in some sense
that's a good idea right because you're
reducing risk and prior research shows
that teens will actually avoid seeking
care if there's a fear for certain types
of care if there's a fear that there
will be an electronic or paper trail so
it sort of solves a problem but what
ends up happening is that many medical
centers will choose an age at which
neither the parent nor the child can
access the record or have any portal
features available and so this is
severely disruptive to families who are
kind of Co managing a chronic illness or
two routines who for teens who feel that
they need electronic access in order to
schedule appointments right and and have
private online communications with their
with their doctors what's really
frustrating to from an HCI point of view
is that we don't know how parents or
teenagers really feel about this so this
is one of the first studies that has
even investigated this phenomenon so you
know there are some focus group studies
that look at attitudes towards health
records but we still need to do a lot of
work to figure out what do we need for
to advance kind of the consistency and
create tools that medical centers could
use to have the fine-grained access
control that they need and the end user
right have the fine-grained access and
sharing controls that the that they need
so fortunately other informants told us
that they saw the medical record as a
communication tool so in interview 8 we
learned that their guiding principle is
the medical record is a communication
tool between patients and their doctors
to limit the availability of information
just doesn't make sense and some put a
lot of additional work into configuring
portal access to accommodate a range of
health needs
to use it as a learning tool so we want
to go back to them learn the specifics
of how they did this and see if we can
use these insights to inform policies
and design work related to improving
multi-party controls going forward okay
so let's move on now to personal systems
and opportunities in this space so I'll
discuss work from two recent papers we
talked about the importance of making
sense of health status and progress in
the clinic
we talked about how patients like Bren
will undergo lots of imaging studies
radiology exams are a way to make sense
of health status and treatment progress
so it might be natural to think that we
can help patients engage better if we
make radiology data available now there
are several reasons why this could be
really challenging to do with radiology
data it's different from other
diagnostic data like lab results lab
results are more constrained in nature
they have these kind of single point
measures they're well-defined and
straightforward in terms of ranges of
what's normal the radiology report
corresponds to image data that is
thousands of cross-sectional slices of
anatomical region and a text report
written by a radiologist who are
interpreting these images by default
these aren't really meant to be
understood by patients so just like lab
results and other medical data it still
can be released at least for those
centers that do allow access and it's
really important to them so we asked how
we can design tools to improve medical
communication about radiology imaging
studies for pediatric patients and their
family members
we situated our work in in the clinic we
conducted an analysis of online health
forum data to gauge patients information
needs related to imaging reports
everything from length of questions and
answers to stylistic considerations and
how they ask questions and explain
things to each other we ran some basic
text analytics on over 200,000 radiology
reports to distill the common phrases
and also some unique phrases we had
seven radiologists review these to get a
better understanding of what functions
these phrases really served in
rapport so in other words certain
phrases can commonly be used to either
refer to anatomy describe attributes
about that Anatomy the size of something
or position of something others
indicated that there were there was
absence or a presence of something and
then of course there were follow-up
suggestions so we paid attention to
actions and recommendations versus
observations we use some of these
insights to design a web application
with a touch based user interface that
was formatted for interaction at a
Microsoft Surface tablet and designed to
handle written content of a CT or MRI
study and ran a pilot study I'll talk a
little bit in a minute about why we
chose to do this on a tablet when I
present the results I think it'll it'll
be a little bit clearer so our goals
based on our on the first two small
studies we collect we conducted we're to
identify and restructure important
sections of the report we're able to use
heuristics to determine structural
features of the report that helped us to
sort of automatically restructure it and
we also wanted to allow users to
identify medical concepts and important
sections of interest so we connected to
MEDLINE plus and other health
communication api's to search for terms
and Auto linked explanations to allow
them to sort of clarify jargon if they
wanted to but within the clinical
context and then of course we wanted to
allow them to select any portion of the
report and associate that portion with
questions and discussion topics but also
in context
so this is going a little bit fast sorry
okay
sorry about what
okay so you can see all of the prior
exams are on the left in this demo so
while we conducted the pilot study on
tablet computers this video was shot on
a desktop so you'll see a mouse doing
the actual selection but the the
selections you see are also enabled
through touch so you can see exams on
the Left choose which report to interact
with and information cards load on the
right these have illustrations and text
for medical definitions allow
interaction with a 3d anatomical model
and it'll localize on that model the the
textual reference we wanted to allow for
definitions even of things that weren't
medical phrases and also allow for some
alternative ways of saying something so
otherwise unremarkable is something that
comes up a lot and we wanted to be able
to clarify what this means right using
using multiple definitions so content
from info cards is automatically made
available to add to a user's notepad
where they can ask questions in the
context of their browsing and navigation
is structured such that a summary is
shown after some basic information of
what the exam is so since we know to
look for things like size and position
of text we were also able to add
reference measures for sizing
information to give people to give
people a more concrete view of what that
might be so we ran a pilot study with
patients parents and oncologists at
Children's Healthcare of Atlanta where
we work we acquired the most recent CT
scan or MRI in most cases the scan was
conducted right there
so once the the scan was conducted in
the report was completed we sort of ran
it by the oncologist and subsequently
loaded it into our prototype several
patients and parents told us
they light kind of being able to quickly
retrieve a friendly explanations what
they really liked is that they didn't
need to filter the quality of the search
so this is still a big deal medical
information search is really difficult
for consumers things tend to be either
really watered down and focused on safe
information that won't get the company
publishing it in trouble or overly
technical literature so this is still
actually actually a really active area
of research
so t13 some of this up well no one's
saying that it helps a lot but before
you'd have to go to Google or another
search engine just to look this up t12
told us that notes would help him keep
track of follow-up instructions and so
again thinking about this for in the
context of wanting to foster self-care
skills tools like this can be really
useful in the clinic interaction with
the report actually led to this really
interesting dynamic interspersing of
report interaction by both patients
parents and clinicians but we found that
by giving the teen a tablet right and
allowing you them to sort of drive the
experience the discussions focused on
them more so than asking the parent and
sort of you know every now and then kind
of checking with the teen the
conversations and discussions were much
more patient-centered just from giving a
tablet with this diagnostic data and
some tools to the team we found that
discussions started out focusing on
technical concepts and sort of defining
what was what but then patients and
parents drew on this technical knowledge
and really quickly to start asking about
other things symptoms disease process
treatment and when answering questions
clinicians demonstrated certain video
spatial concepts by alternating between
sketching physically referencing areas
of their bodies and the patient's bodies
and we observe two of the five
oncologists in our pilot study sketching
out relevant parts on the body on a
drawing on a drawing board on on bed
sheets so it started with some
electronic information retrieval write
driven by the patient turn into kind of
this rich patient driven discussion with
a doctor so in the paper we mentioned a
lot more
findings but one of the things that we
were really excited about was going from
something from an electronic interaction
to then some in-person interactions that
included a lot more than just clicking
and looking something up and and instead
took the turn of gesturing for
explanation and sketching so an ongoing
work we want to develop Tecmo text
analytic capabilities to highlight and
rank elements of previous reports that
relate to a span of user selected text
for any selected span of text in a
report to show targeted comparisons
because patients were really relying on
these heavily to understand progress
over time so now on to a final study
i'll talk about a co design study yeah
destabilize the broader systematics my
sense is that doctors often depart that
role is to control the flow of
information which is why patients who
come and have 10 million going on can be
frustrating sort of like no I I'm the
one who's trained in taking all this
information and synthesizing it into a
result and I wonder if you know this
presented he stabilizes that
relationship in a way that would be
mucus threatening to the doctor or where
they no longer sort of have control over
the the conversation or the information
that's deeper patient yeah it didn't
come up
so overall the oncologist we worked with
were so there's a couple of reasons why
though right so it didn't come up but
when we do research studies like this
physicians are an important part of the
recruitment process so we don't mess it
can't necessarily go in and just sample
randomly right we have to work with
usually the in this case it would be the
the ontology that has ecologist has a
relationship with the patient and make
sure that they're sort of helping us
select patients who are good quote
unquote good candidates usually what
this means is that the patient is stable
enough and the information communicated
wouldn't be so sensitive but you really
shouldn't be delivering it elect
chronically but that also affects then
who has access to this kind of data so
it could be that we didn't hear about it
because they were part of sort of the
selection of who got it
that said I don't know if we could have
done it any differently because when you
do studies like this you sort of have to
rely on their on their direction so but
it's a great question yeah it could have
been replacing this thing EHR systems
like when you were interviewing the
doctors or because I I've done some
stuff in this space and the doctors I
talked to were very not they generally
because they thought it was handing over
control to the patients and basically
the issues that Michael brought out and
so I wonder like when you were
presenting this were you presenting it
in a way to to where this when it like
replaced like my health with epic but it
could be a non get an additional system
right okay I think I think I understand
the question yeah so this was absolutely
not to replace any kind of face to face
you know clinician patient interaction
our goal was actually to supplement that
communication and so first of all we
envision this is being used in the
clinic and probably in a supervised way
when there aren't necessarily changes
that would distress the patient you
could do this before the consultation
and that was one of the use cases but
yeah the oncologist that we worked with
actually suggested to us but this is
absolutely for you know supplementation
right not not replacement I think you
know they were excited about it because
as I kind of mentioned before a lot of
the educational tools really aren't you
know adolescents is such an ambiguous
age and people have a hard time gauging
what's too much right so a lot of the
explanatory materials are really geared
towards younger children and so those
just sort of don't work with teens and
so having something electronic something
that can show them right what's going on
inside your body right in a way that is
a little bit more concrete but that can
be a scaffolded through the
communication that happens with the
clinicians
they saw as overall very positive but
again it's not going to work for every
patient I think that's a really great
question so moving on to personal
systems I'll talk about a final study
today on co.design my final study I
should say today is Co design with teens
with complex chronic illnesses so this
relates to a different type of health
data it's clinically relevant but it
comes from the patient directly so we
are exploring ways of capturing symptom
data
so after Brens diagnosis for example
she'll start chemotherapy and within a
few days of the initial treatment she'll
need to get several lab tests including
baseline bloodwork and what will be
happening is during the course of
treatment her the chemo is gonna be
delivered to destroy cancerous cells in
the body but some of the bodies and
normal cells are also going to be
damaged in the process so once chemo
starts is one side effect the patient's
blood count level is going to decrease
dramatically and then it'll shoot back
up to normal range so that's this red
curve here so this is important to track
because it's a sign of the patient's
immune system and the blood counts
dictate when the patient can receive
their next chemo treatment it usually
takes about three to four weeks to fully
recover blood count levels and so every
patient kind of responds differently to
a chemo agent and so they're asked to
come back a week or two after the first
treatment so the care team can kind of
evaluate the patient's tolerance make
adjustments to the therapy based on kind
of the measured difference between
baseline which would be to zero in this
and this chart and t1 so during this
three to four week period a patient can
experience symptoms and treatment
effects and it's important to capture
these to understand if this is actually
a successful course of treatment or if
it can be successful or if we need to
change course but let's take this image
for example imagine being a parent of
this child and having to figure out
what's going on and and they're not
really opening up to you in part because
they're suffering some of the
cognitive effects right the physical and
emotional distress of having just gone
through their first chemo treatment so
is he in pain is he just fatigued is he
distressed some things are visible right
but other things are not as visible and
while patients are recovering from
treatment there's a significant time
lapse between the last day of the chemo
infusion and the doctor's visit this can
range from about two to three weeks and
symptoms can take many forms right
during this time and will be most severe
actually between visits just at the time
when you're probably less likely to be
thinking about talking to the doctor
because you have another visit coming up
in a couple of weeks so oncologists need
to get a clear understanding of the
patient's status and they'll use
radiology scans blood tests but they
also really heavily rely on patient self
reports about current effects of
treatment dosage on the body and they
also use this for supportive care
opportunities right so to refer when
necessary to a nutritionist to a
psychiatrist
so while clinical data are easily
obtained it's really difficult to get
self-reported data about the illness
experience and incorporate that into
care processes so what we found and
what's been echoed in other studies is
that parents tend to over report and
teens tend to underreport and so this is
it's a very difficult and an under
investigated topic so we're
investigating ways now of capturing
patients health assessments during that
time between visits to the clinic
outside of typical care context to
address problems with recall and
reconciliation between the parent and
the team
so this co.design study asked how we can
support teens communication of their
everyday illness experiences and I'm
referring here to elicitation of these
experiences so fortunately researchers
have created a framework for capturing
observations of daily living so this is
patient defined and patient generated
data
status indicators would be how they're
feeling and this could be physical as
well as emotional behavioral indicators
what they've been doing what they've
been up to and exposures pertain to
socio environmental context so we wanted
to understand if we could use this
framework and elicit these you know
types of everyday illness experiences
but we needed to turn some of these
right make it a little bit more concrete
and turn them into design artifacts to
facilitate some visual storytelling so
we co designed visual observations of
daily living which ended up being a
library of visual illustrations
depicting multiple aspects of the
patient's lived experience so up till
now we've kind of been talking about
delivery of data and user driven
questions about data that's sort of
already there but when we're designing
with teens right in the space to elicit
information from them we have a lot of
different challenges and so I've kind of
outlined them here first building off of
ideas which is something we usually want
to do in a design process in our case
means building on experience we have to
capture the experience - and often the
experience that they've had their
histories right their experience of the
illness directly corresponds to their
ideas many ideas are related to physical
experiences and after all in this case
we also want to design something to
continue to capture those so reconciling
teen and parent reports about the
experience is difficult there's an equal
power relationships there's reduced
means for communicating ideas design
work can be burdensome and there's kind
of a complex web of additional
stakeholders that we have to account for
so there's been some exciting design
research that has helped us understand
how to engage in Co design with kids and
teens we learned for example that teens
understanding of their role and really
what what is their role in this design
process not just kind of we want you to
do a design activity right without
having a clear vision for what that
means but really knowing how are they
to contribute to the outcome what is
their role here is important
re-examining what objectives should be
so not just coming up with a solution at
the end but understanding the value of
the entire process making the engagement
in that process one of the outcomes is
really important and treating child
designers as actually Co researchers
right there
they help us write research gather data
share and enrich the contextual data
that we need and so this is some
exciting work that's also coming to the
fore and work on designing with the
family has recently looked at
relationship building as part of doing
design so accounting for what are the
dynamics here and having the designer
sort of be able to recognize when some
of those design what when some of those
dynamics are at play so when
disagreements might be happening that
would require that we shift right and
that would pivot a design activity so we
generated sketches that patients could
use but we also sketched with them they
could draw or tell us what to draw and
we did this both alone with them and
with family members present they could
indicate things that they wouldn't show
their families and before inviting other
stakeholders in we made sure to to give
them a means for sort of marking this
would just be for me this is something I
would want to share and I'll tell you
how in just a minute
so we based activities or these
behavioral indicators on activities of
daily living self-care quality of life
eating bathing etc teens let us know
that teens in our study let us know that
they wanted some status indicators right
there within the design of these
different artifacts to let us know this
is something I can't do or this is
something I can do really well so for
them tracking activities and engagement
and activities was a really important
part of being able to communicate about
the illness experience itself and so we
kind of created this library some of
some of these things included people
places and finally descriptors and tools
so tools describe a set of media
technologies that the team could bring
into a storyboard we used store
board scaffolding to kind of outline
their observations of daily living we've
specifically presented four scenarios to
draw out illness related experiences and
preferences regarding imagined use of a
technology that could help them capture
these experiences in situ so these
included storyboarding for personal
review communicating with family members
in person and remotely and communicating
with their doctors
I want to point out that this is
different from storyboard scaffolding
approaches such as comic boarding that
start in the beginning with a few
pre-selected images to support idea
generation but then leave the rest
open-ended we actually replace the end
frames with visual illustrations to
correspond to a scenario that they could
be grounded in so that they sort of knew
upfront okay this would be the story
that then I would be sharing in person
or sharing electronically so I'll just
talk about our second and third
scenarios now I don't have time to go
into all of them but our second and
third scenarios pursuit insights into
how family members could work together
to contribute observations as part of
the patient's experience so I'm gonna
combine the findings that I'd like to
highlight today from both in-person and
remote communication parents became
involved in Co design to contribute
their own observations and perspectives
and we saw opportunities for
storyboarding technology to resolve
conflicting perspectives so for example
t9 said tracking these observations of
daily living could serve as a point of
reference to resolve discrepant records
so it recollections scuse me of an
observed experience so he said my
memories not been the best recently with
all the stuff that's going on so usually
it would be me saying something what I
believe is correct and she'll see it
some other way and if I did record what
happened we could just go back and look
at that and that would help a lot when
we asked interview questions about what
each teen and parent understood best
about the patient experience teens
focused on describing personally felt
experiences these are both physical and
emotional and how those affected the
activities that they wanted to do
everyday parents talk more about
meta-level details
timing of things location
frequency so we heard teens saying I'm
if I'm talking about painters symptoms
those would be more of a personal thing
only you know how much it really hurts
and all that it'd be harder to explain
it to someone else I think she referring
to his parent his mom be better at
tracking the time than me t13 echoed
something similar he said I would ask my
mom to record me after I'm done sitting
down how I feel when I'm brushing my
teeth what music does for me and how I
feel so studies like this are
contributing to an emerging space of
family informatics so tracking the
direct felt experience is important
tools should elicit input from both
children and family caregivers Laura
Pina found that families with both
healthy kids in kids with chronic
conditions preferred to consider both
caregivers and children as trackers to
distribute the burden of tracking among
the family and to also look at ripple
effects right so how was a behavior or a
for example an emotional experience
affecting others in the family how we do
this is an open question we can do it
really really poorly and it could go
wrong but it's an emerging area that I
think has promised many patients
describe themselves as the experiencer
of their own subjective feelings while
parental caregivers mentioned tracking
objective details time location
frequency so digital storyboarding
technology could support collaborative
work among families by providing kind of
distinct roles what should you fill in
right for each stakeholder so I'll wrap
up with scenario for going from
scenarios one to four we found that
types of digital media technology that
they wanted to use to capture some of
these experiences change depending on
what they were capturing of course the
paper kind of goes into some of these
relationships but often this had to do
with the expressive potential of
different media and what they wanted to
to capture so teens preferences for
communicating mood were quite mixed we
found that they were very fluent they
were very fluent with sketching and they
were very fluent with communicating on
the storyboard about mood though they
didn't necessary
talk about it very much but because of
the complexity of emotions requiring
rich representations we found in our
analysis of interviews and photos of
storyboards that teens prefer a mix of
both abstract and concrete
representations different facial
expressions as well as sometimes
tracking something what they consider to
be quantitative one out of five how am I
feeling today and to define that scale
themselves so t7 described wanting to
use a chart along with a photo chicken
on his phone you see my highs and lows
mood swings happen almost every day and
needing a mix of tools with that allowed
for different attributes of the
experience to be captured we also saw
that they found videos to be engaging
for them and thought they'd be engaging
for clinicians so t5 for example was
optimistic about the potential for video
to foster more positive patient
clinician interactions that were driven
by the patient saying next time I come
in the nurses could be like that was
such a cool video of your foot so what
does it mean right to sort of think
about the capabilities that we need and
what does it mean to train clinicians to
handle the way that this group expresses
themselves right so this is a question
that we're tackling in my group we have
a lot more on our website so I'll wrap
up now I want to thank my awesome
graduate students I made Matt Hong a
little bit larger here because he was
the first author on many of the studies
that I mentioned today and also thank
some funding sources
[Applause]
it's discussion that's it like how do
you not fear like how do you balance the
the issue of security and privacy that
you mentioned in the first part of your
talk with like having children become so
designers and researchers at the same
time because there's a issue with like
the younger they are the less we 1-8
their hospitals want to give them access
to the records and the data that they
could potentially co.design with but so
I guess like how do you balance those
two
it's an excellent question I mean that's
something that we're hoping to
investigate a lot more certainly things
change when you think about collecting
data from a patient if they can't access
if they can't access the electronic
health record but you're still expecting
them to contribute to it that creates a
lot of problems in terms of visibility
and being able to kind of go in correct
things so I think you know working
through what consistency means and
access to adolescent records it's going
to be really important so we're doing
this design work as research because we
we see it have playing a really
important role but yeah we do need to
work out some some of the the
consistency issues and we're hoping that
we can start pushing policy in the
direction of more consistency that is an
area that is very new to me so so if you
guys have insights into sort of HCI
meeting policy let me know because I
think this is a really important gap to
fill
what do you see is a role of your
technology and higher designing in
preparing the children and doing medical
research a more adult level because I'm
looking back at my regression I didn't
have any of these tools but I think
maybe not having those tools meant I was
more ready to kind of interpret a
radiology report by reading up to date
or mindscape or something like that
where like going between the different
medical assistants they might not have
these interactive tools that you have
so whatever yeah so I see two questions
there but I feel really interesting so
the first session is if you give people
tools are they less likely to sort of
build some of the skills themselves if
you're basically encapsulating some of
those the skills and a tool that
provides some of that for them right
then you're you're potentially you're
potentially robbing them of
opportunities to assess quality let's
say of online materials themselves or to
do some of the some active research
themselves where they have to think
through what kinds of concepts they need
to learn about right and a good
information about and I think that's an
open question
this is also true though in medicine in
general so a lot of the the systems that
we have now in recommending treatments
or in there's benefits right of alarm
systems there's benefits of clinical
decision support but there's also
potential negative impacts when we
relied too much on those systems in
terms of our own cognition their own
ability to solve problems so I think
that's a really important question and I
don't necessarily know I think we need
to kind of look at it right and maybe
compare different groups and how they
problem solve to see what are the
benefits of different approaches the
other question I think relates to
disparities so imagine that you know if
an adolescent just doesn't have access
to the record but you're creating tools
that help adolescents who do right then
you have this effect of you know even
more resources given to people who
already have them
and so you know I think disparities is
something that we also need to address
in health informatics and I'm attending
a CCC workshop on that next week so I'm
hoping to learn more about that but it's
definitely you know reflecting on some
of our work it's like yes this will work
great for kids who are already in who
already have access to organizations who
have thought really carefully about how
to provide records and who want them to
have these learning but you know these
learning materials and tools so but then
you're sort of you're basically making
the disparity dichotomy even more
pronounced through continuing to
innovate for the group that has
resources so these are really good
questions all right up to the front here
you